this is not going well
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by a2 milk
and we'll be reviewing another harper's
bazaar food diaries video and taking a
look at everything that aisha curry eats
in a day
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor a2 milk
so you guys know i'm not vegan and my
family all loves their dairy ice cream
milk cheese yogurt i have yet to meet a
dairy product that i don't love but of
course if you do not eat animal products
that's totally cool this message is not
for you but i hear from people all the
time that they really enjoy dairy and
they want to consume dairy but that they
avoid it because it causes some
digestive distress
and while for a lot of folks this could
be the lactose causing the issue for
others it's actually a unique protein
found in most commercial dairy products
called the a1 beta casein protein so i
was really excited when a2 milk finally
launched in canada because i know that
it's allowed so many people to enjoy
dairy again without the digestive
discomfort it has the exact same calcium
and other essential nutrients found in
traditional milk but it lacks the a1
protein that can be triggering for some
people so a2 milk is 100 canadian fresh
and delicious milk so if you're a dairy
lover like me or someone who has stayed
away because of tummy troubles
definitely give a2 milk a try so you can
pick it up at any of your major grocery
retailers and check out my link in the
description for some more information
okay now before we get into it feel free
to pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating i will be talking
about macros and calories and all sorts
of things so of course feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and if you're new here do
not forget to subscribe to my channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on an episode alrighty
folks let's jump in
first thing i eat in the morning is
typically that morning cup of coffee if
i'm intermittent fasting i'll do it with
a little bit of coconut oil grass-fed
butter and some mct oil if i'm not i
just take my coffee with french vanilla
coffee mate in it okay so
right off the bat we have a little
confusion around intermittent fasting
not that i'm promoting intermittent
fasting
and being like an if dictator but
if you're putting anything with calories
into your coffee
you're not fasting like
fat will technically break a fast as
will protein powders bcaa supplements
and even gummy vitamins some people
still do include sources of fat in their
fasting window because while they may
impair autophagy
they won't kick you out of ketosis which
is part of the alleged benefit of
intermittent fasting
however as i discussed in my video on
intermittent fasting right here
well things like autophagy
insulin suppression and ketosis are
thought to be some of the theoretical
reasons why intermittent fasting results
in weight loss research actually
suggests
that it's much more likely related to
the fact that we just eat fewer calories
when we limit our eating episodes or
windows in the day and we aren't so
great at making up for them adding a
little coconut oil to your coffee isn't
going to make or break your weight loss
in my opinion but if the primary driver
in intermittent fasting success is a
caloric deficit
you're probably better off adding a
splash of milk or cream compared to a
100 calorie tablespoon of oil
just saying now you know and knowing is
half the battle as for her non-fasting
alternative i mean you guys know the
drill i don't critique coffee orders
but i do just gotta say
that it's kind of funny to me to see the
juxtaposition in food choices when the
girl is on versus off her diet it's like
when you're on the diet you know we got
to get that clean overpriced mct oil
grass-fed butter blend for optimal
metabolic boosting power but when we're
off the diet we're going with the coffee
creamer that doesn't even actually
contain any real cream it's actually
just sugar oil and some flavor i mean
it's delicious so i don't judge
but
i do feel like it takes a lot of
flexibility to go from sugar sweet
coffee to black with oil in it as
someone with a very strict coffee ritual
this is something i just don't
understand honestly my mind is blown a
bit but honestly if you guys are able to
go from sugar sweet coffee to black
coffee at a moment's notice without
feeling like you're being deprived in
some way please let me know in the
comments below i just don't understand
how this works personally
if i'm eating breakfast usually on the
weekends a good smoked salmon scramble a
little bit of dill in them salt pepper
i toss in the smoked salmon corn and
shallot and i just love that stuff okay
i gotta say i'm a little turned off by
the if i'm eating breakfast statement
when i hear something like that where
someone only eats breakfast on the
weekend
it tells me that they probably enjoy
breakfast and their body could probably
use breakfasts but there's some explicit
restriction going on and sometimes that
restriction is unintentional because
weekdays tend to be a little busier than
weekends or sometimes it's like a random
diet rule that people are setting for
themselves
i'm gonna guess that it's the latter
with aisha since she did kick off this
interview talking about her intermittent
fasting regimen
as for her scramble this does sound
delicious so we've got fat and protein
in the salmon and eggs but i would love
to see this served with maybe some toast
or some roasted breakfast potatoes for
some fiber rich carbs in there your
traditional ackee and selfish breakfast
with fry dumplings so it's just this
salted cod and you fry it up with onions
and peppers put in the canned ackie and
then make some little fried dumplings
inside of plantain fry okay so i love
that she's representing her heritage
here with this classic jamaican
breakfast spread and i would also say
that it's relatively well balanced so
we've got protein in the salted fish
fiber in the ackee and plantain and some
fat in the oil that it's cooked in now i
really don't want to try to appropriate
a traditional classic dish and sometimes
you just gotta enjoy a dish as it's
traditionally meant to be
but i would say if it was my breakfast i
would probably use the opportunity of
like this kind of scramble situation to
bump up the veggie action by just
throwing in maybe a few more colorful
veggies just to you know add that to the
fry up really like to drink a big 32
ounce cup of hot water i'm not a huge
fan of ice water i don't know why i just
love
good hot water okay so like coffee i
don't really care how you take your
water all water is good water to me so i
say drink your water in whatever form
will be most incentivizing but is there
a benefit to drinking cold water versus
hot water well it depends on your goals
so one study found that drinking hot
fluids was more effective at providing
quick lasting relief from a runny nose
cough sore throat and fatigue when
compared to cold or room temperature
water which is probably why we crave
like a nice warm beverage when we're not
feeling so great
on the other hand there is some research
to suggest that drinking cold water may
help to improve athletic performance and
endurance
and there are even some small studies
that suggest that drinking cold or room
temperature water may result in a teeny
tiny slight boost in energy expenditure
but i would say that the difference in
real life is likely negligible and not
enough to make any kind of measurable
impact on your weight or your health but
it sounds to me that this is just how
aisha likes her water so sounds great to
me i really struggle with lunch i make
sure that the kids are fed and i slip
off and forget to have lunch if i am
having lunch post workout arugula or
spinach salad seared protein on the side
some shrimp tuna salmon poppy seed
dressing a little bit of red onion
chocolate protein shake again
not a fan of the if i'm having lunch
statement
i mean i'm a mom too so i totally
understand the drive as a mom to want to
take care of our kids needs first
but mama
you also need some fuel in that tank
regardless of whether or not you worked
out that day
especially if aisha is skipping
breakfast
also forgetting to have lunch
is just a recipe for a huge afternoon
crash but if you're consistently
struggling to find the time for an
actual sit-down meal having some easy no
prep mini meals or snacks can definitely
help to stand in to provide some
nutrition in our day so this could be
something as easy as a protein bar with
a few pieces of fruit or a pouch of tuna
thrown into a pita or specific to
aisha's situation
i would recommend eating what the kids
are eating so if you're making
sandwiches for the kids just add another
one into the assembly line or if you're
warming up some leftovers
throw a little extra into the microwave
for yourself
again i know that this is easier said
than done and i'm totally guilty of not
nourishing my body when time is really
limited too
but we have to take care of ourselves
before we can take care of others
as for her sometimes post-workout lunch
meal
now we are getting some protein from the
shrimp tuna and salmon plus some
micronutrients and fiber from the greens
and some fats from the poppy seed
dressing
but i would love to see more carbs in
her post-workout meal to really help to
replenish those glycogen stores so maybe
we could throw in some roasted sweet
potatoes or some quinoa into that salad
as well as some sort of fresh or dried
fruit i would also be wary about
overdoing it on the protein post workout
and i would choose to have the meal with
the source of protein or the protein
shake instead of both at the exact same
time but i would way rather see that
shake earlier on in the day to just
spread out the muscle supporting love
fitness wasn't really a part of my
lifestyle the past year and a half it's
really become
a staple for me and so i do try to work
out at least five days a week so i love
that aisha describes her relationship
with fitness as something that makes her
you know really happy and provides her
with some mental clarity and i also love
that she tries to switch it up and keep
things interesting so i talk about this
in my youtube video on joyful movement
right here but i do find that you know
finding an activity that you truly enjoy
rather than just doing it exclusively
for weight loss purposes is so important
to ensuring that it's more sustainable
activity
i am not a huge snacker i gravitate
towards banana chips carrot sticks or
cucumbers i try and keep my snacking
pretty healthy these days huh
no breakfast
no lunch
and no snacks
[Music]
got it when is this girl's energy gonna
crash
like i'm mildly concerned about
how little fuel
is in her usual day
as for the snacks that she does
sometimes choose i mean the carrot
sticks and cucumbers on their own are a
pretty low calorie snack which while
certainly healthy and refreshing
really wouldn't keep you very satiated
so if we hunger crush and combo it we
could throw in some hummus or guacamole
for dipping or some cheese and crackers
on the side
i also do love me some banana chips but
i would personally try to pair them with
maybe some nuts or seeds for a little
diy trail mix which would totally up the
satiety factor so that aisha didn't feel
that she needed to go through them like
crazy
my absolute favorite meal to cook oxtail
rice and peas and fried plantain that is
the food that i grew up with and it just
brings me so much comfort and joy when i
make it because it reminds me of my
family and just makes me feel like i'm
close to them so this to me is just such
a great reminder of the importance of
food in preserving culture identity and
it's really nice that she can maintain
some of her family's traditions despite
being so far away from her hometown
and i love that she's a fellow
torontonian represent look at this we
created this yeah we do have some really
awesome jamaican food here
typically like to eat dinner around
seven you know we check in with each
other see how our day was going dinner
for us these days looks fast simple and
easy i mean those are my kind of meals
too and i love that she's created really
easy accessible recipes for lots of busy
families just like her because
honestly i also have way too many days
where even 30 minutes to make a meal
seems like too much but 20 minutes
20 i can do this girl gets me did we
just become best friends yep really
that's where my focus is when it comes
to preparing the meal for my family it's
not breakfast it's not lunch it's it's
definitely dinner because that's the
time i know we're gonna get to sit
around the table together so you guys
know i say it all the time family meals
are so important so research suggests
that diet quality improves when we eat
as a family so we eat greater amounts of
fruits and vegetables and fewer fried
foods or high sugar foods
now family meals also help to improve
our children's language skills and
reduce the risk of disordered eating
obesity drug abuse early sexual activity
behavioral problems depression and
struggles in school i believe that this
is probably one of the most important
things that we can do for our kids
health i love whiskey sours i love a
good margarita a good mezcal mard and if
i'm not doing hard liquor or cocktail
i'm usually doing a big bold red cab all
great choices to me
but here's a really interesting little
factoid on palette development so
apparently our preference for sweet
things levels out to like adult
preference levels during middle to late
adolescence which also coincides with
the cessation of physical growth so it's
been proposed that a preference towards
sweet things in childhood is actually
hardwired as a biological drive to eat
more energy dense foods now i still
admittedly love me a good german
riesling so
i don't know maybe i still have a bit of
growing to do i want to be 510 like
cindy crawford the last little thing to
me reaching my best fitness goals is
probably eliminating the late night
snacking i love ketchup chips all
dressed chips if it's not that some type
of donut maybe once or twice a week i
can't shake it i'll get there someday so
i just want to make it clear that snacks
are not a universal barrier to meeting
health or fitness goals even if you're
snacking later on in the evening like
your body does not see that it's 8 pm on
your phone and then say like oh great
cool send those calories straight to her
bun
in fact like ask any fitness competitor
lots of snacks are often very
strategically used to support fitness
goals so obviously just really depends
on what you're snacking on and typically
we do tend to gravitate towards more
processed higher calorie foods like
chips or sweets at the end of the day
when we're a little more tired or our
willpower is down
but based on this interview so far
it's clear that aisha often skips
breakfast because she's intermittent
fasting and skips lunch because she
forgets
so it's really not surprising to me that
she's ravenous before bed so if you find
yourself binging in the evening
make sure that you're getting in a solid
breakfast lunch and a few saturating
snacks throughout the day so remember
the hunger crushing combo and try to
apply that as often as you can
also if your goals require you to never
have a potato chip or a donut again
i don't know
i guess i would probably want to
reevaluate whether or not that's
actually a healthy goal
how about new we also know that
completely eliminating foods that you
love
is typically a set up for a binge and
it's a lot better to have a donut like
twice a week than have no doughnuts for
a week and then have a baker's dozen all
in one go
so on that note what can we say about
aisha's diet
well there are things here that i really
like
and some things
not so much what i like is that aisha
knows the importance of food in bringing
together family and maintaining her
cultural identity she's also obviously
an amazing chef and definitely knows a
few things about food so i have no doubt
that dinners in her house
even if they take just 20 minutes
are probably pretty great but that is
really all there is consistently going
on
just dinner
on what sounds like her regular busy
work days
there is just not nearly enough food
i mean the fact that she mentioned going
through tons of banana chips and needing
to eat ketchup chips before bed or
donuts is really not surprising to me at
all
because her body is likely begging for
the calories it's being deprived of all
day long
now had aisha had breakfast and lunch
every day and not just on the weekends
or on days she doesn't forget
she probably would be able to get to
dinner with a normal size appetite and
then not have to play calorie ketchup in
the hours leading up to bed this is such
a common cycle that i see people
especially women fall into where really
they restrict all day either consciously
or unconsciously and then they overeat
after dinner only to then not have an
appetite in the morning again to justify
further restriction
and honestly one of my favorite parts of
this interview was aisha waxing poetic
about the importance of family dinner
and if she'd only just apply that same
enthusiasm to the other two meals of the
day
she would probably be able to see better
blood sugar appetite and energy levels
all day long
and she might actually be better able to
meet her fitness goals because she isn't
getting to 9 pm needing to door dash
donuts
so the moral of today's story is really
to invest in your body's nutritional
needs
it deserves to eat regular meals and
snacks every single day
feeding yourself should be top priority
on your to-do list it should be above
working out above curling your hair
above checking tick tock
it shouldn't be limited to days that
you're off your diet or when you've
earned a meal through exercise your body
needs to trust that you're going to feed
it consistently
more than once a day
and if you're a mom please remember that
you're probably not your best self when
you're hungry and on that note i am
hungry so yeah i'm gonna go eat now but
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me a few next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
you